Continuing with our tour of the last 48 hours
and on Fox News.
Fox brought on a guest that was too crazy
even for Fox News in terms of the Corona virus
disinformation that he was willing to spread.
This is just the best.
Fox News is a primary disseminator of disinformation
about the virus.
They all do it.
Fox and Friends.
HANNITY Judge Jeanine, the whole lot of them.
Sean HANNITY brings on a guy named Alex Berenson.
Now, you just look at Alex Berenson and you
you can tell he's off in some way and he has
become a darling of Fox News because he's
willing to say a lot of the crazy things that
many people are not willing to say because
they are crazy things to say.
So he shows up on Hannity's program and he
says, hey, you're under 30.
There's no risk if you're a kid or a baby,
you're not at risk from coronavirus.
And it's so crazy and so wrong that even Sean
HANNITY can't.
Tolerated and has to interrupt him and call
him out.
And B, my concern has been that the that the
the public health consequences, as well as
the economic consequences, as well as the
societal consequences of locking down the
whole country, have been massively understated.
And let me just give you one example of that.
In kids, children, almost anybody under 30
is at no risk to this.
No serious risk from this virus.
I'm not saying.
Well, that.
Well, I say.
Hang on a sec.
Hold on.
Let me let me roll that, Charles.
How about that, Alex?
That changed in the middle.
Because you're right.
Everybody was told us if you're not if you
don't have a compromised immune system or
underlying health issues, if you're younger,
you gonna be fine.
But that changed.
And if you looked at the hospitalizations
in New York that children those numbers changed.
And by shutting down the schools, by shutting
down schools.
We haven't just denied children in education
for a lot of kids who might be in abusive
homes, who might be in homes with parents
who are drug users.
We're denying those children really any eye
on them from an adult.
HANNITY Having to jump in and say, no, no,
no, no.
Everybody's at risk.
You are not in the clear because you're 25
or because you're a kid.
And then again, later in the segment, Berenson
starts talking about opening retail and other
stuff.
And HANNITY, again, has to point out, I don't
agree with a lot of what you're saying.
But if there this fall, maybe we can open
retail and we can open hospitality.
We need metrics and we need reporters who
are going to ask the president.
I like governors like Carrie Kahn and not
just say and not just make things look as
bad as possible.
I like your iconoclastic.
And you're definitely making people think
and it takes a lot of guts doing what you
do.
And I don't fully agree with it, but I appreciate
you being with us.
Thank you.
If Sean HANNITY is distancing himself from
a corona virus contrarian, you know the guy
is nuts and or that HANNITY doesn't want to
get sued for spreading disinformation about
the virus.
Now, the truly irresponsible thing about the
entire, you know, kids are not at risk story.
Twenty five year olds are not at risk story
that neither Berentson nor HANNITY bring up
is that aside from whether a 25 year old is
at risk of a serious case of the virus or
death themselves.
Put that aside for a moment.
They are spreaders.
What Alex Berenson seems to not be willing
to say or maybe he doesn't understand, is
that if you don't close schools and the kids
get it, even if they don't get a serious case,
they bring it home to their parents who then
may give it to coworkers or grandparents.
And it's a nightmare.
They are so wrong at this point that it has
become so predictable.
And by the way, hundreds of young Americans
have now been killed by Corona virus, 7:59
dead under 50 as of five days ago.
Many more now.
And as of last Wednesday, six New York residents
under the age of 20 had actually died.
These people have to stop.
Fox News seems to have very little interest
in stopping other than to avoid lawsuits,
which they now believe they are at at risk
of.